. This is sort of becoming a more interesting
news story to me.
Now, as many of you know, we did not cover
the Meghan Markle Prince Harry interview with
Oprah on the podcast or on the broadcast show.
We did talk about why these stories do well
on yesterday's bonus show, but we didn't talk
about the actual interview on the broadcast.
I just didn't really seem like a story for
our show.
There's now kind of like an ancillary or a
tangential media story which is developed
around this, which is that British journalist
and TV personality Piers Morgan, who at one
point actually had a nightly show in the United
States, stormed off the set of Good Morning
Britain yesterday and then subsequently quit
or was fired.
It's one of those situations where we don't
know.
I had no idea of the full back story on this.
And it's quite interesting in how thin skinned
appears appears to be.
Apparently, Piers Morgan has been displeased
with Meghan Markle, the duchess of Sussex,
for a long time.
And part of it might be that he tried to date
her and she wasn't interested.
Check out this video where he explains that
they went on what I'm hearing described as
a date and then she ghosted him.
Take a look.
We had two hours in the pub.
She had a couple of dirty martinis of a couple
of pints.
We got on brilliantly and then I put her in
a cab and it turned out to be a cab that took
her to a party where she met Prince Harry.
And then the next night they had a solo dinner
together.
And that was the last I ever heard from megabuck.
I have never heard from her again.
So what happened is she goes to meet Ryan,
Meghan Markle goes to.
Did she do you think she just went.
I'm afraid I really liked this is what I really
said.
So this almost appears to be a personal thing
for Piers based on that.
And this, unbeknownst to me, until I learned
about all of it, has led to Piers making lots
of negative comments about Meghan Markle over
the years.
Again, I don't follow the stuff.
I learned all of it in the last 24 hours.
So then over the last couple of days, Piers
has continued to attack Megan, saying that
her claims about British royal family being
concerned about her son's skin color is completely
fabricated, that the British royal family
isn't racist, that Meghan Markle is lying
Piers.
Just defending the royals and attacking Meghan
Markle.
Yesterday on Good Morning Britain, his co-host,
Alex Berrisford, essentially said, Piers,
what you've been saying is disgusting.
And Piers Morgan literally walks off the set.
Take a look.
And I understand that you don't make a mockery.
You've made it so clear a number of times
on this program, a number of times.
And I understand that you've got a personal
relationship with Malcolm had one and she
cut you off.
She's entitled to cut you off if she wants
to.
How she said anything about you since she
cut you off?
I don't think she has.
But yet you continue to trash her.
OK, I'm done with it.
No, no, no.
It's all right.
No, I don't know what.
That's a good track record.
Maybe not.
But, you know, I'm sorry, because that's absolutely
diabolical behavior.
You see, I'm sorry, but Piers spouts off on
a regular basis and we all have to sit there
and listen six, 30 to seven o'clock.
Yesterday was incredibly hard to watch.
So Piers Morgan walking off there.
And then subsequently after this episode yesterday,
it was abruptly announced by ITV that Piers
Morgan is departing Good Morning, Britain.
The official statement is that, quote, Following
discussions with ITV, Piers Morgan has decided
now is the time to leave.
Now, the wording doesn't tell us whether Piers
Morgan decided that because he was told by
ITV, you should decide that it's time to leave.
We don't know.
We may never know.
For me, the worst part of all of this and
what makes me want to talk about it is that
Piers Morgan on Monday said he doesn't believe
Meghan Markle was truly suicidal.
One of the things that came up during the
interview with Oprah Winfrey that was revealed
by Meghan Markle was that she she was having
suicidal thoughts.
I really don't care about the royal family.
As you know, it's not something we cover other
than to say that it's an antiquated apparatus,
an institution.
My concerns are journalistic ethics, harm
reduction, people's health, media ethics.
In this type of thing.
We are in a mental health crisis exacerbated
by the pandemic with so much stigma around
seeking treatment and such lack of access
to mental health treatment in the United States
and in many other countries.
And someone notable publicly saying I was
suicidal, I was thinking of taking my own
life.
And then someone as prominent as Piers Morgan
says, I doubt whether that's really true.
I think she might have been making it up.
That's a disaster and it's dangerous and it
could actually lead to more suicide.
Now, I don't care about Piers.
He's wealthy.
He'll find other jobs.
He'll be fine in all ways.
But fundamentally, he's always struck me as
an insecure guy.
There's instances of him making fun of reality
show contestants in ways that seem to kind
of go beyond what would be normal just for
entertainment.
But this is really just beyond the pale and
it all kind of falling apart before our very
eyes in the last 24 hours.
And the risk is that by casting doubt on you
know, we know that, for example, we know that
one reason that rape accuser sometimes don't
come forward is fear that they won't be believed.
And much the same way, Piers saying he doubts
the truth of whether someone claiming to have
been suicidal was really suicidal.
That's only going to encourage people who
need help not to seek it.
And it could have disastrous consequences.
So that's that's the most vile and disgusting
aspect of this.
I'm interested also in hearing from you what
your thoughts are about the entire fiasco.